[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann angelo von mir
und das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
ein impfstoff mehr zur wahl für über
18-jährige empfiehlt die stiko jetzt
auch nova wachs und für besonders
gefährdete eine zweite
auffrischungsimpfung
vergeltung im medien streit moskau
verbietet der deutschen welle dass
senden in russland weil die deutsche
medienaufsicht den russischen staat
sender rte in deutschland gestoppt habt
eine flagge zwei geehrte claudia
pechstein und francesco friedrich dürfen
bei der olympia-eröffnungsfeier morgen
die deutsche fahne tragen
zwei wichtige nachrichten kommen von der
ständigen impfkommission zum einen
empfiehlt sie eine vierte impfung und
zwar den über 70-jährigen medizinischen
personal und besonders gefährdeten und
die stiko spricht sich für nowaks aus
dieser neue impfstoff könnte eine
alternative sein für all jene die den
bisherigen präparaten gegenüber
skeptisch sind der unterschied m rna
impfstoffe wie biontech und moderner
enthalten eine art bauanleitung der
körper baut sich dann teile des virus
nämlich spike proteine es folgt eine
immunabwehr bei protein impfstoffen wie
nova wachs sind dagegen die spike
proteine schon im wirkstoff enthalten
dominik müller russ l
die nächste im bunde steht also an viel
zu organisieren den st josef hospital
buchung und vielleicht lassen sich nun
da die stiko mit nova wachs einen
proteine im stoff empfiehlt die auch die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im haus
überzeugen die bislang noch ungeimpft
sind und ganz allgemein gesprochen auch
die menschen im land die den m rna
impfstoffen misstrauen und im
schlimmsten fall dann bei ihnen
ungeimpft auf der intensivstation landen
wir wissen ja ob das sie begründet ist
oder nicht dass einige doch gegenüber
die gegen bei den neuartigen impfstoffen
ressentiments haben und er die
altbekannten impfstoff oder ähnliche
haben wollen und im prinzip glaube ich
daher dass wir eine große gruppe der
bevölkerung damit ansprechen und ich
habe die hoffnung und auch eine gewisse
zuversicht dass uns das gelingen wird
die stiko hat sich heute außerdem für
eine vierte impfung nicht nur für
medizinisches personal ausgesprochen
sondern auch für menschen ab 70 und für
menschen mit einer immunschwäche
auch wenn damit zwar kein völliger
schutz vor corona hergestellt werden
kann die studie nahe liegen aber dennoch
es gibt jetzt mittlerweile ja die ersten
daten aus israel seit ganz wenigen tagen
und die zeigen dass man durch diesen
zweiten muss dann nochmals ein höheres
niveau der schutzwirkung erreicht und
dieses niveau würden wir gerne für die
menschen mit risiko für schwere
erkrankung erreichen die impfkampagne
könnte wieder fahrt aufnehmen anfang
märz sollen die ersten 1,4 millionen
dosen nowaks in deutschland zur
verfügung stehen
haben sie fragen zu den neuen
impfempfehlungen antworten gibt evers
von der ständigen impfkommission gleich
um 19 uhr 30 bei heute live in der zdf-
heute- app und auf unseren social media
kanälen das robert koch institut meldet
auch heute neue höchststände innerhalb
von 24 stunden haben sich mehr als
236.000 menschen mit dem corona virus
infiziert das sind fast 33.000 mehr als
vor einer woche
164 todesfälle kamen hinzu die inzidenz
steigt auf
1283 2 experten gehen davon aus dass
viele fälle nicht erfasst werden weil
test labore und gesundheitsämter am
limit sind
das ohnehin schon angespannte verhältnis
zwischen russland und deutschland hat
einen weiteren dämpfer bekommen gestern
hatte die deutsche medienaufsicht die
verbreitung des russischen staates
senders rte hierzulande gestoppt heute
reagiert der kreml und verbietet die
deutsche welle der unabhängige
auslandssender darf in russland nicht
mehr senden und berichten antwort der
bundesregierung das sei nicht hinnehmbar
alexandra vacano
moskau am frühen abend das büro der
deutschen welle dass schließen muss fünf
korrespondenten sowie weiteren
mitarbeitenden wird die akkreditierung
entzogen das verurteilen die öffentlich
rechtlichen sender in einer gemeinsamen
stellungnahme
wir verurteilen die schließungen der
büros der deutschen welle in russland
hier wird freie unabhängige
berichterstattung radikal eingeschränkt
und politischen druck auszuüben dass
damit zugleich die pressefreiheit zum
faustpfand gemacht wird erfüllt uns mit
großer sorge die erste reaktion aus der
politik das sendeverbot nicht hinnehmbar
so die staatsministerin für kultur und
medien ich appelliere daher eindringlich
an die russische seite die
lizenzrechtlichen probleme des senders
rtl für eine politische reaktion zu
missbrauchen
auslöser für den konflikt seit mitte
dezember sendet der russische staat
sender sein deutschsprachiges
fernsehprogramm jedoch ohne lizenz das
entscheidungsgremium der medienanstalten
ist zu der überzeugung gelangt dass die
rt productions gmbh mit sitz in berlin
an solchen eigenständigen
eigenverantwortlichen fernsehsender
betreibt und deswegen lizenz wichtig ist
eine solche fernsehen lizenz liegt aber
uns nicht vor und deswegen waren wir von
amts wegen gehalten den sendebetrieb zu
untersagen
russia today deutschland sendet direkt
aus berlin und wird direkt finanziert
aus dem russischen staatshaushalt
rtd ist ja faktisch ein russischer
staatssender da geht es um propaganda da
geht es darum stimmung zu machen dieser
sender ist absolut abhängig vom
russischen staat und man hat den
eindruck eben auch ganz klar
weisungsgebunden mit diesem neuen
konflikt erreichen die beziehungen zu
moskau einen neuen tiefpunkt
axel sturm in moskau wie ist dieser
schritt des kreml einzuschätzen
na ja das ist natürlich schwer dass zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt zu tun aber ganz klar
ist es das ist eine knallharte
politische entscheidung eine
entscheidung gegen deutsche
medienvertreterinnen und medienvertreter
hier in russland und leider auch eine
entscheidung gegen die pressefreiheit
wie wir sie im vergangenen jahr so oft
erlebt haben und worüber wir so oft
berichtet haben die akkreditierung der
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
deutschen welle laufen offenbar morgen
schon aus die sendelizenz ist weg das
moskauer büro soll geschlossen werden
das ist ein wirklich großer harter
schnitt und es ist angekündigt worden
morgen gegen 11 uhr ortszeit soll es ein
briefing geben im außenministerium denn
in der verlautbarung von heute
nachmittag steht dies sei ein erster
schritt ist also weiter weiteres
ungemach zu erwarten die einschätzung
unseres korrespondenten aus moskau dankl
axel sturm
auch in der ukraine krise sendet
russland bisher kein zeichen des
einlenkens das diplomatische ringen um
eine friedliche lösung des konflikts
ging heute weiter zugleich hat die nato
damit begonnen ihre truppen in
osteuropäischen mitgliedsländern wie
litauen und polen zu verstärken gunnar
krüger berichtet den überblick waren
nicht leicht bei soviel truppenzahlen
5000 soldaten hat die nato seit jahren
in ihrer ostflanke die bundeswehr etwa
hilft den luftraum mit radarbildern zu
sichern deutschland führt den litauen
sogar das kommando und stellt derzeit
550 soldaten doch das kleine land sehe
gerne mehr vom großen freund deutschland
die zeit spricht mit vielen nato
partnern über zusätzliche
rückversicherungen
sicherheitsgarantien und mehr truppen
wir überlassen die entscheidung aber den
anderen wir müssen das intern
diskutieren hat keine pläne für mehr
truppen und brüssel also die nato hat
nur weitere zahlen über russische
truppen in den letzten tagen beobachten
wir große russische truppenverlegungen
nach belarus das ist das grösste
russische aufgebot dort seit dem kalten
krieg
30.000 soldaten und schweres gerät habe
russland nach belarus fällig darum
machen sie sich auch von north carolina
nach rumänien und polen die usa warten
nicht auf die nato schicken 2.000
soldaten und holen sich in moskau den
vorwurf ab säbelrasseln
wir bitten die amerikaner ständig die
spannungen in europa nicht zu erhöhen
aber sie machen immer weiter in der
ukraine der beim besuch eines unsteten
nato partners der türkische präsident
will zwischen der ukraine und russland
vermitteln eine chance für die
diplomatie von unerwarteter seite
die ukraine krise war auch thema beim
abschluss der winterklausur der
csu-landesgruppe in berlin die
bundesregierung gebe da ein zerrüttetes
bild ab kritisiert csu-chef söder alles
andere als zerrüttet dagegen die
beziehung zum frischgebackenen
cdu-vorsitzenden märz bei ihrem ersten
gemeinsamen auftritt beschworen die
beiden unions chefs ihre einigkeit das
vergangene jahr sei geschichte aus
berlin daniel putzen es klang zeitweise
wie beim handy wo zwei reuiger
ex-partner immer wieder etwa liest man
einander den vortritt
noch vor wenigen monaten warf man sich
gegenseitig vor stillos respektlos gar
übel haft zu sein beziehungsweise
erfahrungen vor allem aus den 90er
jahren einzubringen zuletzt aber habe
man in kontakt gehabt das wird eine
richtig gute stabile und auch sehr
kollegiale freundschaftliche
zusammenarbeit werden die haben das
gesamte jahr 2021 hinter uns gelassen
das ist geschichte es ist tatsächlich so
wäre ein schweres jahr 2021 hinter uns
gebracht mit vielen vielen schwächen und
fehlern und wir haben daraus gelernt
aber wir haben auch eine neue
verantwortung diese neue verantwortung
bedeutet auch neue kraft zu schöpfen
vereint übte man sodann kritik an der
ampel vor allem mit blick auf russland
jüngst hatte sich sogar selbst noch
skeptisch bezüglich deutsche
waffenlieferungen und neuer sanktionen
gegen russland geäußert
nun aber gab man sich einig dass
russland alleiniger aggressor sei diese
klarheit vermisse man beim kanzler was
macht eigentlich olaf scholz wir sind
etwas überrascht weil man hat ja
unterschiedliche kanzler lebt mit
unterschiedlichem temperament aber eine
solches also gespannt bleiben für
deutschland und für europa und auch für
die politische friedensordnung dieses
kontinents ist das ein desaster
dass der bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland im augenblick
offensichtlich gelähmt und blockiert ist
in dem was er vielleicht tun könnte
jedenfalls tun musste wer von den beiden
möglicherweise selbst als
kanzlerkandidat antritt bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl werde man frühzeitig
entscheiden gegebenenfalls mit hilfe
eines gremiums die fehler des letzten
jahres jedenfalls werde man nicht
wiederholen
sie spüren dass alle beim einkaufen beim
tanken vieles ist deutlich teurer
geworden die inflationsrate ist so hoch
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht mehr doch mit
einer anderen zins politik gegensteuern
das will die europäische zentralbank
weiterhin erstmal nicht sie hält an
ihrer umstrittenen nullzinspolitik fest
vorerst jedenfalls peter theißen
fast alles wird teurer auch auf dem
wochenmarkt
kartoffel 260 blum code vier euro letzte
hd 360 gekostet wir haben jetzt bestellt
1000 3000 euro sind dort strom hat jetzt
aufgeschlagen lebensmittelkosten quasi
wie es weitergehen soll mit den preisen
steigt auch der druck auf die ezb die
inflation mit höheren leitzinsen zu
bekämpfen doch auch heute keine bewegung
allerdings schließt die ezb chefin
zinsschritte noch in diesem jahr nicht
mehr aus
wir wissen dass die last vor allem von
denen getragen wird die am
verwundbarsten sind und sich jeden tag
mit den schwierigkeiten durch höhere
preise auseinander setzen müssen und ich
versichere ihnen diese sorge treibt das
gesamte ezb-direktorium um
allerdings immer noch hält man in der
ezb die hohe inflation für ein
vorübergehendes phänomen
im laufe des jahres werde sie wieder
abnehmen wenn auch später als bisher
erwartet
derzeit aber scheint sich die
preisspirale immer noch weiter zu drehen
einige warnen bereits vor einer
verfestigung der inflation das kann
passieren
dadurch dass lohnverhandlungen deutlich
höher ausfallen als sonst oder dass man
sich allgemein an hohe inflationsraten
gewöhnen und das ist aufgabe der
notenbank mit einer solchen situation
signale zu senden dass die inflation
bekämpft wird immerhin die ezb hat heute
angekündigt sollte die inflation hoch
bleiben werde sie alle instrumente
auspacken um sie möglichst bald wieder
auf zwei prozent zu bringen
aus protest gegen die bucks it
kontrollen hat der nordirische
regierungschef port gewinn seinen
rücktritt angekündigt damit steht die
regionalregierung vor dem aus gestern
abend hatte das nordirische
landwirtschaftsministerium angeordnet
britische agrar produkte nicht mehr zu
kontrollieren
das sei gesetzeswidrig sagt der
koalitionspartner das benachbarte eu
mitglied irland und auch die eu bei
einem anti-terror-einsatz von us-truppen
in syrien ist der anführer der terror
mit salsa chemie getötet worden er soll
auch für den jüngsten angriff auf ein
gefängnis im nordosten des landes
verantwortlich gewesen sein die
us-soldaten hatten ihn in der provinz
idlib in der nähe der türkischen grenze
aufgespürt al haschimi habe sich vor
seiner verhaftung selbst in die luft
gesprengt und dabei mehrere frauen und
kinder getötet so die us-regierung
die katholische kirche in deutschland
steht unter enormem druck groß sind die
erwartungen an die dritte synodale
versammlung und es mehren sich die
forderungen nach einem ende des
pflichtzölibats der vorsitzende der
deutschen bischofskonferenz georg
bätzing sagte er sei dafür dass es
priestern freigestellt werde ob sie
ehelos leben wollen zuvor hatte sich der
münchner kardinal reinhard marx gegen
den zölibat ausgesprochen
der schauspieler dieter mann ist tot er
starb im alter von 80 jahren mann war
vor allem auf der theaterbühne zu hause
für einige jahre war er intendant des
deutschen theaters in berlin er spielt
aber auch in kinofilmen mit unter
anderem in der untergang
2020 hatte ihn der bundesverband
schauspiel für sein lebenswerk
ausgezeichnet
und das auch noch vor der nordseeinsel
wangerooge ist an ein containerschiff
havariert seit einem tag liegt es dort
fest die fast 400 meter lange mumbai
märz war auf dem weg von rotterdam nach
bremerhaven beim ansteuern der
wesermündung sei das schiff auf gelaufen
heißt es von den behörden ein erster
versuch den frachter frei zu schleppen
scheiterte in der kommenden nacht soll
die bergung mit der flut und stärkeren
schleppern gelingen
warum ist es soweit norbert
eröffnungsfeier der winterspiele punkt
13 uhr unserer zeit das zdf überträgt
live das team deutschland das wird wie
schon in tokio von einer frau und einem
mann angeführt diesmal tragen rekord
olympionikin claudia pechstein und bob
dominator francesco friedrich die
deutsche flagge für das deutsche
erfolgsduo ist es nicht nur eine große
ehre sondern die krönung ihres gesamten
sportlerlebens
das macht mich überglücklich und vor
allem ist es der i-punkt auf meiner
karriere acht spieler jetzt dann als
deutschlands erfolgreichste winter
olympioniken und dann die fahne noch und
danach gemeinsam mit meinem freund
francesco das ist wie sowieso ein
ritterschlag in england hier bei uns
hier die deutsche mannschaft mit der
verein zu führen also das ist schon
bestimmt mindestens gleich zu setzen mit
der goldmedaille die wir hier gewinnen
können gewählt wurde das duo per
online-voting von den fans und den
deutschen athleten die 49 jährige
claudia pechstein läuft bereits am tag
nach der eröffnung ihr erstes rennen
friedrich startet die mission
doppel-gold am 14 februar
sechs neue kroner fälle im deutschen
olympia-team das meldet heute der dmsb
den fonds am austragungsort zhangjiakou
was ist sonst bekannt
ja die sechs teammitglieder der
deutschen mannschaft wurden noch am
flughafen isoliert und nochmals getestet
die ergebnisse gibt es dann morgen was
wir wissen ist dass sich auf diesen
flieger von frankfurt nach peking die
deutsche eishockey-nationalmannschaft
befand teile des skeleton teams und die
nordischen kombinierer und der dsv der
deutsche skiverband hat uns gegenüber
bestätigt dass er auch betroffen ist das
würde dann für die kombinierer sprechen
es kann auch immer noch sein dass all
diese tests falsch positiv waren aber
wenn nicht dann wäre das ein denkbar
schlechter start für das team d in die
olympischen spiele von peking
dank des 5 1 für diese information die
fußball-nationalmannschaft des senegal
steht wieder im finale des afrika cups
das team besiegte gestern abend burkina
faso herausragend liverpool star money
als torschütze zum 3 1-endstand senegal
trifft im finale am sonntag auf kanonen
oder
aufgegriffen
das war so ein spruch dankeschön aufwand
beim wetter zieht eine kaltfront auf es
wird wieder ungemütlich mehr dazu hat
gleich aus dem verlies im heute journal
um viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie bettina
schausten
hier übernimmt morgen mitri sirin wir
sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen und beschwerten abend und
alles gute
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter haben eigentlich
ist es die kälteste zeit des jahres
jetzt anfang februar aber erneut
erreicht uns milde luft aus dem
südwesten und so gibt es teilweise
zweistellige werte aber die kaltfront
hier die sorgt für abkühlung aus dem
nordwesten kommt kältere luft aber nicht
so richtig kalte luft wie man sie im
februar erwarten würde in der nacht gibt
es einzelne schauer die ziehen
allmählich nach nordosten hin ab und die
temperatur sinkt auf frostige werte
einzig an den alpen auf minus 3 grad
sonst 7 grad im westen deutschlands
morgen vormittag liegt die kaltfront
ganz im nordwesten schon mit schweren
sturmböen und kräftigen schauern das
verlagert sich dann zum nachmittag
weiter in richtung mitte zunächst wird
der wind aus südwest und dann dreht er
auf nordwest und ist ziemlich kräftig
teils mit schweren sturmböen gewitter
sind auch inklusive ganz im süden zeigt
sich auch vorher noch die sonne die
temperaturen dazu fünf grad nach osten
und 10 grad ganz im westen und im
südwesten
am samstag gibt es einzelne schauer in
den bergen durchaus mal mit schnee sonst
im süden viel sonne bei drei bis neun
grad aber am sonntag erreicht uns der
nächste heftige sturm damit ein schöner
abend